me han pedido hacer más ejercicios sobre
límites así que hagamos algunos más
veamos cuál es el primer ejercicio que
tengo vamos a calcular el límite cuando
x se aproxima a cero cuando x se
aproxima a 0 de x menos 2 veces el valor
absoluto de x y todo eso todo eso lo
vamos a dividir entre el valor absoluto
de x ahora lo que confunde a mucha gente
es el valor absoluto de x porque como
operamos con él
no podemos restarlo así tal cual porque
no es una x cualquiera
podríamos restar 2x y dividir entre x
pero esto tiene un valor absoluto así
que no podemos hacerlo de manera directa
bueno qué pasaría entonces si pudiéramos
deshacernos de este valor absoluto de x
y para que lo que quiero ver es que para
que este límite exista digamos que fuera
un número l
este número él es el que tenemos que
resolver entonces para que éste exista
debe ser
de igual cuando nos aproximamos por
números positivos que cuando nos
aproximamos por números negativos
digamos el límite cuando x tiende a 0
por la derecha es decir nos aproximamos
por los números positivos
x menos 2 veces el valor absoluto de x
sobre el valor absoluto de x debe ser
igual al número l además debemos
encontrar que el límite cuando x tiende
a 0 por la izquierda de x menos 2 veces
el valor absoluto de x sobre el valor
absoluto de x también debe ser ese
número l no es así si esto fuera así si
nosotros digamos a medida que nos
aproximamos por ambos lados podemos
descubrir que el límite es el mismo
entonces habremos encontrado el valor
exacto de l así que vamos a averiguar
cuáles son estos dos límites digamos y
vamos a empezar primero con el límite
cuando x tiende por el lado positivo
bueno
ponemos el límite cuando x tiende a 0
por el lado positivo entonces si sabemos
que nos aproximamos por el lado positivo
entonces como es el valor absoluto de x
entonces si x es positiva
en realidad el valor absoluto de x es x
verdad y simplemente sustituimos de esta
forma así que aquí igual a este límite
este es el límite cuando x tiende a 0
por la derecha de x menos 2x que es
menos x esto es menos x verdad y luego
dividimos menos x entre x eso es igual a
menos 1 verdad entonces este límite
simplemente es menos 1 va a ser menos 1
correcto lo estamos enmarcando para que
sea sea claro ahora tomemos el caso en
donde nos acercamos desde el lado
negativo
ok como podremos pensar en esto bueno
cuál es el valor absoluto de x si x es
un número negativo pues el valor
absoluto de x será menos x verdad puesto
que es un número negativo entonces al
sustituir o bueno podemos pensarlo de
esta manera si x es menos 1 cuando nos
aproximamos digamos por distintos
valores no por ejemplo si x es menos 1
el valor absoluto de x es uno que es
simplemente tomar el negativo así que en
resumidas cuentas el límite cuando x
tiende a cero por la izquierda de x
menos 2 valor absoluto de x será menos
2 por el valor absoluto de x que es
menos x xi perfecto entonces esto nos
queda x menos dos por menos x muy bien
porque el valor absoluto de un número
negativo es menos ese número y bueno eso
es lo que hace que se vuelva positivo
verdad en esencialmente y ahora
dividimos entre el denominador que es
menos x - x
vamos a ver cómo simplificar esto esto
será el límite cuando x tiende a 0 por
la izquierda
veamos x menos 2 por menos x en realidad
es más más 2 x perfecto entonces arriba
en el numerador tengo x 2 x que son 3 x
esto es 3 x y luego dividimos entre
menos x verdad esto es igual a menos 33
x entre menos x es menos 3 esto es
interesante porque nos estamos
aproximando a un número por el lado
derecho y por el lado izquierdo y por el
lado derecho me dice que es menos 1 y
desde el lado izquierdo es menos 3
entonces parece que el límite no existe
vamos a confirmar esto déjenme ver si
puedo conseguir la gráfica en y
confirmar geométricamente que esto sea
cierto entonces voy a mostrar la gráfica
de la función x menos valor absoluto de
x espero no se aburran en lo que pongo
esto
todo esto sobre el valor absoluto de x
verdad
sobre el valor absoluto de x
veamos
ok la gráfica y que tenemos acá se me
alejó un poco
entonces esto es correcto tenemos a
aclaró ya vi es que tenemos dos veces el
valor absoluto de x 11 así que le
ponemos el 2 ahí y ya estamos listos
ahora sí vamos a dar la gráfica y ahí
está inclusive
bueno me parece que no lo pueden ver
todavía ahí está la gráfica confirme el
trabajo que hicimos aunque bueno aquí
tenemos este salto esta recta en
diagonal porque es la forma en que el
programa calcula la gráfica verdad es no
es tan precisa pero bueno aquí
intuitivamente se ve que si nos
aproximamos por el lado derecho nos da
menos 1 y por el izquierdo nos da menos
así que podemos decir que el límite no
está definido así que ya tenemos un
truco un truco un poco sucio algunos
dicen de cómo calcular el límite pero
bueno si no sabemos cómo resolverlo
analíticamente podemos utilizar estas
estrategias también podemos utilizar no
sea hacerlo numéricamente por ejemplo
qué pasaría si x es 0.0001 y vamos
viendo qué pasa del lado derecho y del
lado izquierdo así que numéricamente si
tienes una calculadora podrías cálculo y
podrías determinar este límite
de cualquier manera hagamos otro
problema
invertir color es perfecto ahora hagamos
el límite
el límite de cuando x se aproxima a 0 de
quien vamos a poner de seno de 5x y todo
esto sobre 2x perfecto esto esto es
parecido al límite de seno de x / x
verdad y ya sabemos que es seno de x / x
el límite cuando x tiende a 0 es una
verdad déjenme lo escribo el límite
cuando x tiende a cero de seno de x / x
es igual a 1 entonces esto es muy
parecido se ve casi igual de hecho salvo
por algunos números así que como
podremos resolverlo vamos a intentar
hacer una sustitución vamos a tomar una
variable que sea igual a 5x entonces
déjenme hago la sustitución en magenta
digamos que a sea igual a 5x
esto significa dividiendo ambos lados
por 5 que x es igual a entre 5 entonces
si hacemos esta sustitución el límite
cuando x tiende a 0 en realidad como se
traduce en la variable a cuando x se
aproxima a 0 a también se aproxima a 0
verdad porque a es 5 x entonces el
límite cuando x tiende a digo también lo
puedes ver en la segunda actuación
verdad si x tiende a 0 quien tiene que
ser a pues tiene que ser cero hoy ya me
equivoqué déjenme borro
hola demonios no alcanza
no alcanzo esto pero bueno esto va a ser
el límite cuando atiende a 0
de quien ahora hacemos la sustitución
verdad porque a 5x
nada más quiero remarcar un poquito que
realmente es cuando atiende a 0 se puede
ver de la primera actuación espero allá
que haya quedado claro así que tendremos
seno de a entre dos equis pero x es
sobre 5 así que así es cómo queda la
sustitución y esto va a ser igual al
límite cuando atiende a 0
nos aproximamos a 0 de seno de a seno de
a sobre dos quintos de add verdad
simplemente manipulando un poco el
denominador y el dos quintos es una
constante en realidad es uno en dos
quintos así que sale del límite y se
invierte verdad por la propiedad del
sándwich así que esto es uno sobre dos
quintos que es cinco medios sólo estoy
sacando del límite y esto es el límite
límite cuando atiende a cero de seno de
a
seno de a sobre a y ahora sí ahora esto
es idénticamente a lo que teníamos en
amarillo sólo que en vez de x tengo a
entonces no hay ningún problema esto es
igual a 1 y si multiplicamos por 5
medios entonces el límite nos resulta
ser 5 medios que
si ya tuviste la respuesta y no estás
del todo seguro bueno pues toma tu
calculadora y calcula el seno de 5 x
0.001 que es 0 05.00 5 y luego divide en
3 puntos 0 0 2 verdad esto es tomando x
igual a punto 0 0 1 y entonces
aproximadamente te va a dar 1.5 que son
5 medios o algo así no estoy seguro
cuánto cuánto sea pero bueno hagamos
otro ejercicio para calcular límites
ok
entonces vamos a tener ahora el límite a
medida de que x se acerca a 0
este se parece mucho a un ejercicio
previo vas a ver del seno cuadrado de x
sobre x cuadrada
y esto casi se parece al seno de x / x
pero aquí tenemos cuadrado en ambos así
que qué hacemos en este caso entonces
esto será lo mismo que el límite cuando
x se aproxima a 0 de seno de x
/ equis y todo esto al cuadrado verdad
porque si elevamos al cuadrado a ambas
partes nos queda justamente lo que
teníamos arriba verdad entonces
no no puedo decir que estamos
simplificando realmente estamos
cambiando la expresión de esta forma y
esto elevará al cuadrado en realidad es
hacer una operación constante así que
esto lo podemos ver como el límite
cuando x tiende a cero de seno de x / x
al cuadrado todo eso al cuadrado y como
es esto
este si yo había tenido en el exponente
una equis bueno yo no lo hubiera podido
hacer pero es una constante en cierto
sentido así que lo único que va a
cambiar es lo que tenemos elevando al
cuadrado así que tomamos el límite de la
base y podemos obtener el límite
completo así que otra vez tenemos la
propiedad del límite cuando x tiende a
cero de seno de x entre x que es 1 esto
es 1 y al elevarlo al cuadrado será 1
ahí está y tome 13 minutos de tu tiempo
espero que los hayas encontrado al menos
útiles